there you know this is just I'm just
saying by and large the average salary
is like 35
000 a year for women so like by and
large women aren't climbing the
corporate ladder like there are some
right maybe like 10 15 but I would say
like by and large it's more just like it
was fun so they want to have fun yeah so
you you believe that women modern women
are deriving enjoyment from that Pro
promiscuity structure they're they're
you believe they're not unhappy no I
think they're unhappy like how do I put
it when the consequences happen so like
when they sleep with a bunch of people
and then like everyone finds out and
they're like oh you know now but do
I think like to start yeah they're
having fun and then you know life
catches up to you it's kind of like you
eat 10 cheeseburgers every time you eat
the cheeseburger it's fun you're happy
but then you're 300 pounds Rebecca so
that's that's how I see it